hey everyone it's sarah with  registerednessrn.com and in this video  i'm going to demonstrate how to assess  the sucking reflex in a newborn  and just like the rooting reflex the  sucking reflex helps the baby  feed it's going to play a role with  nutrition so  you will see this whenever something  touches the top  of the infant's mouth on the inside it's  specifically that hard palate of the  mouth so the roof of the mouth the  infant will actually automatically just  start  sucking it's an involuntary thing that  happens  so again this helps the infant with  feeding by allowing the infant to pull  food from its food source like the  breast or a bottle  now this reflex tends to disappear at  about four months and it will actually  become a voluntary function  okay so that wraps up this video on how  to assess the sucking reflex in a  newborn and be sure to check out the  other videos in this series